in this comic Godzilla kills God and
it's amazing check this out so this
takes place in a comic called Godzilla
in Hell spans for five issues written by
five different people the art styles
change from issue to issue so you'll see
a change over the course of this video
so basically Godzilla is sent to Hell
after effectively destroying the Earth
with his Atomic breath and as soon as he
gets there there's just this giant sign
right abandon all hope ye who enter here
which Godzilla doesn't care anything
about uses his Atomic breath and just
like destroys the entirety of this thing
and then just starts like traversing his
way through hell and as he does this
like this giant tentacle monster comes
out of nowhere and just like attacks him
and then he just obliterates this thing
because he's Godzilla and that's what he
does after this he comes across just
like what looks like a giant Cloud off
in the distance and Godzilla right ever
the Curious guy you can't fault him for
that rolls up on this Cloud only to find
out that it's just a boatload of humans
the one thing Godzilla does not care
anything about why because it's like the
whole Godzilla Mythos for him to just
like show up on Earth every so often
smack Humanity around a little bit and
then go back home right so literally
Godzilla just like makes his way through
this cloud of human beings only to come
across a demonic Godzilla now having
said that I know a little bit about the
Godzilla Mythos so if this dude actually
exists and actually has a name post it
down below in the comments section but I
got to say man a demonic looking
Godzilla looks amazing and he even just
like morphs into just this gigantic evil
looking entity type thing and like
Godzilla doesn't care because like this
dude like wraps his tentacles around him
and just like starts smacking Godzilla
around the way Hulk just smacked Loki
around in the first Avengers movie which
just feels and hits different now after
the end of the Loki series but like
Godzilla just doesn't care right he's
just like dude come on man like if
that's all you got if that's if that's
like if this is like the greatest of
threats here then like I'll be out of
this place and I'll be back home in time
for cornflakes because like this thing
tries to like pull Godzilla in and it
actually does right it like pulls
Godzilla into itself it seems like it's
basically one and then Godzilla just
like literally blows this thing to
pieces and he's like next the funny
thing about this is like this kind of
portal opens up below him and Godzilla
falls down to another level right so
then when that happens right as he's
making his way through here he's just
kind of like exploring there's like this
gigantic devil pterodactyl that looks
like Rodan and it probably is some
demonic version of this thing that like
kind of swoops around him and hangs out
and then it decides the best thing that
it should do is attack Godzilla which is
a terrible decision because Godzilla
just like obliterates this thing in one
hit literally he hits it with his tail
once and this thing just like crashes
down into one of the do cities in hell
and then Godzilla just leaves but when
he does right once he gets out here
there's just like this giant dragon
looking creature which looks more like a
leviathan than anything else although
technically I think they're referring to
Godzilla as a leviathan in this the
battle's kind of cool right I'm not
going to lie it is kind of awesome but
like again much like with that Rodan
looking thing Godzilla just takes this
thing out and like one hit and like
that's it which is just kind of amazing
to see because it's like dude there's
all these like gigantic just demonic
crazy looking creatures and like none of
it matters to Godzilla because he's the
king of monsters like of course he would
crush these guys the real question is
why aren't they following him around
right you would think they would realize
how dominant Godzilla is and just be
like I'm going to go hang out with that
dude because it's better to be on the
devil's right hand than in his path but
the crazy thing here is that even when
this creature is more or less destroyed
by Godzilla that's when King gadora
emerges now here's the thing son son son
I know enough about Godzilla to know
that kadora is not the guy to be slept
on right like this dude is on a whole
different level unfortunately we don't
even get to see a full fight between the
two of them because as soon as king Ador
shows up he just like kind of opens this
portal or at least the Portal's open and
then Godzilla just like falls down into
it so you never get to see Godzilla and
King gadora fight in Hell which would
have been amazing had we been able to
see that but following that you
basically switch over to zilan kind of
like this demonic representation of
essentially Earth and specifically like
Brazil right the giant statue of Jesus
that exists out there but the funny
thing here is you basically have like
space Godzilla like this demonic looking
space Godzilla I always thought space
Godzilla was kind of cool I always
thought he looked more like a Power
Rangers villain than anything else but I
always did think he looked kind of cool
but the funny thing here is like with
space Godzilla like he literally attacks
Godzilla himself and sets him on fire
which is kind kind of amazing right so
you literally have like Godzilla who's
engulfed in flames fighting space
Godzilla and it's dope the battle is so
intense that like it lets off this
massive kind of atomic explosion and
blows up like this version of Earth
essentially right like this hellish
version of Earth but then like Godzilla
wakes up in what basically looks like
heaven and it's like this Giant mountain
that exists out there and there's all
like these butterfly dudes who were kind
of coming out of nowhere I know I know
it looks like Godzilla has just
literally started tripping balls right
like Godzilla's on acid so the thing
here is that even when Godzilla gets to
this mountain he tries to like climb it
and it immediately just like pushes him
off right he has like nothing for this
and then in turn he's just told like
submit serve peace serf peace surf peace
right so this is clearly God right
that's literally who this guy represents
I think it's kind of weird that God is
just a giant a morphous blob of eyes and
teeth surrounded by butterfly people but
it is kind of interesting right because
like when one of them decides to fly
down and be Godzilla's friend Godzilla
helps them understand what happens when
you try to be Godzilla's friend bad
things happen like it sucks to be
friends with Godzilla because when
you're friends with Godzilla you die and
that's what happens to this dude this
dude gets killed so God gets pissed off
opens a portal and B ises Godzilla back
to hell so then in turn Godzilla just
kind of like wakes up here and like
space Godzilla reemerges again just like
God's laughing at him like literally
God's laughing at Godzilla Godzilla's
like okay cool man I'm not going to
forget this like just so you know I'm
coming back and I'm going clap God's
cheeks so the thing about this is
Godzilla faces off against space
Godzilla again but in the midst of this
whole fight like while he's being
taunted which in effect this is more or
less Satan kind of manifesting as space
Godzilla if we're being honest with
ourselves like God decides to lend
Godzilla a hand even though Godzilla is
eating all the little evil you know
demonic henchmen type people of of the
devil and then in turn like sends all
the little butterfly people from Heaven
down to Hell to help Godzilla basically
defeat like Satan which is kind of a
cool thing because Godzilla in turn just
like absorbs all this like Divine energy
so even when Satan's just like blasting
him with his breath it doesn't make any
difference Godzilla just like blows this
dude apart with his Atomic breath and
then like literally God opens a portal
up and it's like hey man so like now
that you've defeated Satan and basically
ended the war against good and evil you
want to come hang out and Godzilla's
like no man but I didn't forget the time
that you sent me down here like 20
minutes ago so now everybody's got to
die and he just like blasts the whole
thing with like his Atomic breath
literally uses the power of God against
God and seemingly the dude's obliterated
along with all the butterfly people
because Godzilla eats the rest of them
and so finally Godzilla ends up coming
across this being who's more powerful
than God and Satan literally this being
who exists out there that guards the
gates of people trying to escape this
afterlife and getting back to the land
of the living and it's kind of messed up
the way that it looks right it's just
like almost reminiscent of the way that
God looked but instead it's like this
giant kind of like cthulu looking
tentacle monster that sits at Top This
Tower right like this giant rock Tower
more or less and like when it seeds
Godzilla Godzilla tries to climb up the
mountain and it just like swats him away
like with the greatest of ease well
technically creates a giant landslide
that comes crashing down and buries
Godzilla but like nothing Godzilla can
do is able to overcome this guy so in
turn Godzilla just allows all these just
like evil forces that initially worked
for Satan and now that he's basically
out of of the picture like they've been
following him the whole time so in turn
like they consume the entirety of
Godzilla's flesh right down to the bone
the crazy thing about this is that
Godzilla was still powered by Divine
energy so when that happens they all
effectively become henchmen of Godzilla
they start working for him and so then
they all just start like firing off
their atomic breath all at once
literally just like millions of these
things right it's like it's like Goku
doing the Kamehameha when he was firing
it off like he was literally charging it
up when he was up in the sky above cell
and then like teleported down at the
last minute and fired it off in probably
like the greatest moment ever in the
history of Dragon Ball Z dude it was
dope when that happen but like all this
Atomic breath gets fired off at once and
just like obliterates this tentacle
monster and so after that Godzilla
basically escapes hell and then is
reborn back on Earth as the Godzilla we
all know and love does anything about
this comic make sense not really but
it's a comic book about a giant lizard
that screams like a girl shooting Atomic
breath out of his mouth stop asking
questions with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end
thank you all for watching I will catch
you all later peace